bill skarsgård isn't a household name
yet but to give it time he's the younger
brother of The Legend of Tarzan star
Alexander Skarsgard and the son of
veteran actor stellan skarsgård and this
emerging star is set to make a name for
himself as a terrifying Pennywise in the
upcoming big-screen adaptation of
Stephen King's classic novel it's the
demonic clown was brilliantly played by
Tim Curry in the 1990 TV mini-series
version of the book so skarsgård have
some big clown shoes to fill but he also
has more acting experience than you
might think
here are a few projects you may have
seen him in on the kingdom at Rhodes and
under the knight Templar and on the
kingdom at Rhodes and were combined into
one epic cut for international release
in 2010 though in Sweden they were
released as two separate films based on
a fictional hero on Magnussen Bill's
father Stellan played armed uncle Birju
and reprised the role for the sequel
bringing his son bel into play Eric son
of the king played by Bill's older
brother Gustav the skarsgård field epic
two-parter is the most expensive Swedish
film of all time costing around 30
million dollars Kenny begins skarsgård
went from a deadly serious historical
epic to a completely ridiculous sci-fi
comedy in 2009 Kenny begins a feature
than 3/4 Swedish TV series Kenny
Starfighter Kenny is a hopeless galaxy
hero who crashed lands on earth and
meets cars guards of sponsors and
equally unfortunate fifteen-year-old
with terrible eyesight and the problem
with local police Simple Simon scars
guards next performance not only
impressed domestic critics it also won
plenty of praise stateside The Hollywood
Reporter said 2010 Simple Simon performs
the neat trick of finding laughs and
wisdom about a central character who
suffers from Asperger's syndrome yet
does so without trivializing the serious
nature of the affliction and course
guards guards performance superb behind
blue skies while The Hollywood Reporter
was impressed by Simple Simon their
review of the second bill skarsgård film
to come out in 2010 for seventy satire
behind the blue skies wasn't quite as
kind satirical pokes at Swedish society
at the time are unlikely to strike too
many chords overseas well there are some
appealing performances the picture seems
bound
a cloudy time beyond home territory
still it wasn't all bad singling
skarsgård out to praises performance as
Martin a troubled boy with an abusive
father variety argued that he makes the
most of a real star turn in this
joyously clever take on the
coming-of-age story honor Karenina
making his english-language debut
skarsgård appeared in a minor supporting
role in the 2012 British historical
romance on a Karenina an adaptation of
Leo Tolstoy his classic novel of the
same name
unfortunately for skarsgård the project
he chose as his maiden voyage into
English cinema was a story that for
years had been deemed impossible to
successfully adapt due to the sprawling
nature of the source material reviews
were mixed and the box office results
were lukewarm Hemlock Grove Netflix
original series Hemlock Grove got off to
a great start in 2013 pulling in more
viewers over its release weekend than
house of cards interest in the Eli Roth
werewolf thriller soon began to wane
however and the Netflix announced that
the third season would be its last
skarsgård played sookie vampire-like
creature Roman Godfrey who uses his
supernatural powers to get what he wants
allegiant dystopian teen franchises
became big business in Hollywood after
the Hunger Games but they can't all be
blockbusters case in points the
divergent series which suffered
diminishing returns at the box office
and progressively worse reviews over the
course of its first three installments
plot something out with 2016 Allegiant
it was all a learning experience for
skarsgård who played Matthew a scientist
sympathetic to the protagonist course if
the franchise failed to live up to
expectations the second-generation staff
said he used it as an example of a
lesson had taken from his father even if
it was the worst most horrendous
production and the movie turns out
garbage whatever it is the experience
was something that he learned from and
he wouldn't want to live without atomic
blonde before terrorizing the kids of
Derry Maine in its scars guards appeared
in what he described as a small but fun
part playing a German Punk in atomic
bomb the feature-length adaptation of
Anthony Johnson Cold War Set spy
thriller graphic novel the coldest city
starring Charlize Theron atomic blonde
earned a largely positive reviews from
critics and it's got franchise potential
a prequel to the coldest city entitled
the coldest winter was published in 2016
whether skarsgård will return remains to
be seen either way expect the brooding
Swede to pop up with increasing
regularity in Hollywood over the next
few years thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check all this cool stuff
we know you'll love
[Music]